Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192. David P,
here is a caller. This is the guy who calls in his
connections. Always very strange. It sounds like
a 1930s phone connection. It's very interesting.
He very strongly and powerfully denounces paywalls
and reminds me to remind you, we produced the show
and you can watch it for free. This is a good guy.
Speaker 5: David. I know you got a lot going
on in your in your show. Yes. You've got a lot
of stuff to get through and live any time.
And maybe that's part of the reason why you
slipped up this time and you forgot to mention
when you ask people to subscribe, remind them
this is not something they have to pull off, put a
credit card out. Correct. They can go on on their
computer and subscribe and not worry about having
a paywall. It's free. You forgot to mention that.
So I'm reminding you a suggestion. Maybe for a
sticky note pass. Below the monitor or whatever.
You look at the camera so that you can read
it and you can be reminded. You can remind
yourself to mention subscriptions. There are no.
Speaker 1: Charge. That's exactly right. And of
course, this gentleman is talking about podcast
and YouTube, folks. We're giving it away. We're
giving it away. The entire YouTube show is free.
You subscribe. Free on YouTube. The audio podcast
is free. Now, the way we pay for that is there's
advertising. And if you want to get rid of the
advertising, you get a membership on my website.
Speaking of the membership, the membership gets
you the bonus show. On today's bonus show, we will
talk about the FCC commissioner calling for a tick
tock ban. Wow. We will talk about how predatory
gambling has helped the lottery reach this sky
high jackpot that so many people have written to
me about. And we have polling from Pennsylvania,
which finds 7% of Pennsylvania voters have
been dissuaded from voting for John Fetterman
because of his stroke. All of those stories
and more on today's bonus show. Sign up at